THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF
"RAPID REFRESH."
IT'S NOW TIME FOR THE HASHTAG
WARS.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET BUT
HALLOWEEN IS FRIDAY.
IF YOU WANT TO SCARE KIDS TODAY
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO COME UP
WITH COSTUMES THAT SPEAK TO
THEM.
SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#MILLENIALMONSTERS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE BASIC WITCHES.
OR PINTEREST-HEAD.
OR CREATURE FROM THE BLACK
SKINNY JEANS.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60-- THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH SKINNY JEANS.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GO.
ARI.
>> SOME OF MY BEST FRIENDS ARE
BLACKULA.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
BOBBY.
>> I TOTES KNOW WHAT YOU DID
LAST SUMMER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
>> FREDDIE UBER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
>> WOLF BLITZER.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
BOBBY.
>> SLENDER MAN!
SLENDER MAN!
SLENDER MAN.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
ARI.
>> YODO -- YOU ONLY DIE ONCE,
BRO.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
>> O.M.-GODZILLA.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
BOBBY.
>> THE WHINING.
>> CHRIS: OH, GOD! I CAN'T GIVE
YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
BOBBY.
>> RESCUE PET CEMETERY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
THAT'S END OF "#HASHTAGWARS."